hi if you're related to me in any way
most specifically one of my parents you
shouldn't watch this video you're not
missing out this video will be a little
gross
it will be uncomfortable it will be dumb
and it will be gross and uncomfortable
so I'm not held accountable because I
warned you please mom this is just for
my mom mom don't you don't need to watch
this and my aunt and also everyone else
that's related to me just not not for
you hi my name is grace Helbig if you
did not know now you know your life is
different now there's a very huge trend
that's been happening on the internet
and specifically YouTube a hundred
layers of something 100 layers of makeup
100 layers of lasagne I saw Nicki Lima
do it it's a great video watch if you
haven't seen it yet hundred slices of
cheese and a grilled cheese sandwich
Hannah Hart great job a hundred layers
of clothing ClevverTV all the girls over
there I'm obsessed with you
congratulations great job you can
already tell by the title of this video
I'm not doing a hundred layers of
anything because I'm lazy and doing a
hundred layers of things requires hours
and hours and hours so I decided I was
gonna give you 100 words or phrases to
refer to your vagina mom I told you that
you haven't stopped watching please stop
watching now did you send this
helicopter to make me stop this so I
wouldn't do this and embarrass the
family I have to do this I have to
embarrass the family it's my brand I got
stuck in traffic today for like an hour
and just started coming up with words
and phrases to refer to vaginas other
than the word vagina and it made me
laugh I decided to keep going until I
had 100 of them now look all of these
came from my brain however I'm sure
plenty of these you've probably heard
before in some variation because there's
only you know so many ways you can
describe a vagina
unlike vaginas I'm not claiming that
these words to describe them a
completely original in any way ok let's
just get into this these are no
particular order I don't know what
particular order you would put them in
tube slide skin covered tube soft
Devil's Den sex sauna haunted house the
Batcave slip and slide sperm eteri
confinement
patty-cake I'm so sorry dick Jagger the
ouch couch I bone charger the baby brain
stormer cumference room baby gaga
Destiny's Child upper thigh third wheel
red rash and beyond mom I know you love
that store I'm sorry Badge of Courage
Speaker of the House Harry otter or the
Chamber of Secrets or the Chamber of
Secrets pocketbook bounce house a [ __ ]
pop Lucy no balls like Lucille Ball the
aggro badge
the Geiger crack razor cooter Penn State
University the Great Barrier queef
Clint Eastwood or how about Hillary
Clinton I mean she does have the
Democratic presidential BAM nom nom
nomination oh my god princess Harry
Harry oh then come more Harold and Kumar
they go to the place that I officially
called my vagina the White Castle ah
easy fake oven Christina Aguilera roast
beef sandwich the petting zoo Please
Touch Museum a dick Donald's happy meal
Puss in Boots badge atlantique tampon
casket urethra Franklin egg carton Egg
McMuffin ThighMaster crime master thy
master lie master remember the tight
ones by cloud Trader Joe's I don't own a
gun but I do own a revolver mr. Toad's
Wild Ride fuller house uncle messy the
surgeon genital Kylie Jenner's lips kit
Krampus dude processor the pink Power
Ranger Pikachu Jigglypuff a pokey spot a
pokey stop subscription box new key jar
Chateau camel toe torpedo grotto the
phallus Palace castle castle frustration
nation Creation Station a fetus thesis
spouse house your lifetime achievement
award the sword wars the hammer Manor
studio apartment armored car bread
basket crab champ bread bow ladle cradle
the breadwinner loner owner
scissor wizard a flute wetsuit potted
plant balloon cocoon Sarah Jessica Pete
clear fallopian utopian Southwest
Airlines introverted balloon animal JP
orgasm chase like your bank or your
other banks smells far go bend a dick
cumbersome badge what so there you go
there's a hundred words and phrases you
can use to refer to your vagina I tried
to create a wide spectrum of people with
a wide variety of vaginas maybe some of
these appeal to you maybe some of these
appeal that you I just wanted to
participate if you hated enjoyed or just
completely and utterly cringed at this
video please subscribe to my youtube
channel I'm happy you're here let's
continue this I promise I won't do this
for a while unless you want me to create
a hundred words and phrases for the
penis because that might only be fair
fair trade
there's 199 more to go I don't come you
can already tell by the title of this
video I'm not doing a hundred layers of
anything I'm not that layered as a human
being no one let I'm a nun I'm an onion
I smell like onions nor do I smell like
onions I'm not an onion Goose please I
have to do this and no you don't want me
to but I have to the psych ward like
just kidding
you've thought your have sex with me no
way get out of your psyche so